So let's see how should we do the correct out of order for
the execution. We should execute out of order. We can broadcast out of order.
But we should deposit values to registers in order.
This is needed because if we deposit register values out of order.
If subsequently we discover that one of the earlier,
the instruction shouldn't have been done. Like, it has an exception or
it's a branch misprediction then this instruction has already deposited it and
it shouldn't have. So if we deposit in-order, this cannot happen.
We will basically deposit results in order so once we get to deposit.
That means that all the previous instructions have finished successfully and
everything is fine. In Tomasulo's algorithm this is not happening in order.
This is happening out of order which is why we have a problem.
So what we need is a structure called reorder buffer. Even after issue,
it remembers the program order. And it keeps the results of
instructions until they're safe to write to registers. So basically, instead of
writing to registers whenever the result is produced, it would end up in
the reorder buffer. And then, we will go in order through the reorder buffer and
deposit results into the registers. And once the result is deposited to
the register, only then the instruction is considered fully done.